well a lot of people have asked me to
give my opinion on this gay Jesus
Netflix Christmas special if you hadn't
heard about it here's the daily wire
Netflix is catching major heat after the
streaming service added a
christmas-themed dark comedy made by a
Brazilian comedy group about quote gay
Jesus over 1.2 million Christians have
signed a change.org petition asking
Netflix to remove a the special titled
the first temptation of christ according
to LGBT website pink news the Brazilian
comedy group porta dos fundos which
literally means backdoor is comprised of
five people from Rio de Janeiro who
started making sketches and parodies in
their YouTube channel Jesus is in the
special Jesus is turning 30 and brings a
surprise guest to meet the family a
Christmas special so wrong that it must
be from comedians porta dos fundos the
film was described on Netflix the first
temptation of Christ has been slammed as
blasphemous and disrespectful by
Brazilian Christians many identifying as
Catholics various people have chimed in
it is a serious offence against Jesus
Christ and the Christians there's no
historical evidence to support the
insinuations presented one petitioner
one petition signer wrote according to
pink news and so you get the idea
I'll tell you why I've been hesitant to
talk about this because this is
obviously nothing but cheap stupid
witless provocation by this
quote-unquote comedy group this is this
is the equivalent of someone making a
fart noise in your face if it's even
that sophisticated I mean I think even
that's probably over selling it a little
bit they're begging for attention they
want you to be outraged but they haven't
really earned it they haven't earned
your outrage part of me feels like
getting mad about this is like getting
mad at someone for making a your mama
joke now it could it could be perfectly
warranted for you to be upset or angry
when someone insults your mother but if
they do it in the form of a your mama
joke then it's not worth your energy
right and so part of me feels like
that's the case here and and all of what
I'm saying now would hold true if this
comedy group and you just have to
imagine the air quotes every time I say
comedy group but if this group had had
just made this dumb video put it on
youtube or something like that and that
was that then I would say well there's
there's there's there's nothing for us
to talk about
we shouldn't react to it we shouldn't
give these morons our attention but
that's not what happened
Netflix picked it up Netflix a billion
dollar company one of the most one of
them now one of the most powerful media
companies in the world they lent it
their tacit endorsement and are now
distributing this video putting in front
in front of millions of people's
eyeballs and that's why if if we take
our faith seriously and we have any
self-respect
then we do have to speak out against it
even though as I said I understand the
argument of don't even pay attention to
it these people are total idiots but
it's not about them it's really about
Netflix and in fact the stupidity of it
the the absolute idiocy as at some point
I'm gonna remember to turn my phone on
silent when I do a show you know I'm a
professional if you hadn't noticed but
really the stupidity the idiocy of it
idiocy of it it just it just makes it
all the more worthy of condemnation when
you add in the Netflix factor because
it's not like this is some brilliant and
provocative cinematic work okay the Last
Temptation of Christ that Scorsese movie
which is sacrilegious and blasphemous
came out thirty years ago in the 80s or
90s or whatever it was and I don't know
if Netflix has that on their on their
platform they probably do but they could
always use the excuse of well this is a
this is a legitimate movie made by one
of the great masters in Hollywood which
is true and so we're gonna put it on the
platform now I think it's a it's a
really bad movie on top of being
sacrilegious and blasphemous it's
Scorsese's worst filled by I think a
long shot
but at least they can use that excuse
they're not with this this is again
entirely witless lacking in any kind of
real humor or intelligence the whole
joke is just hey Jesus is gay haha
that's that's the whole thing so you
might as well you might as well have a
guy standing in front of the camera for
forty-five minutes saying that over and
over again because that's the entire
joke that's the punchline that's all
there is going on the point is even from
the perspective of the godless folks
over at Netflix there was nothing here
that warranted it being added to their
platform no artistic quality no comedic
quality to it nothing the only thing is
that it was smack in the face to
Christians so Netflix added it to their
platform solely and and entirely because
it's it spits in the face of Christians
so Netflix obviously felt that yeah well
there's there's not much going on here
but it it spits in the face of
Christians so we like it we're gonna add
it for that reason and for no other
reason and if that's the message if
that's what Netflix is saying to us if
they're saying we we hate you we don't
respect you we don't want your business
then I think we should give them what
they want which is the loss of our
business this isn't even a boycott this
isn't about boycotting or anything like
that this is a company saying screw you
people we hate you we don't want your
money
and so what are we supposed to say but
okay fine it's like if you go to a
person's house party and they make it
clear from the moment you walk in the
door that they don't want you there they
hate you they don't respect you are you
gonna stay at the party why you just
stay at the party when you're not
welcome it's uncomfortable you're being
abused
you're gonna leave it's not even that
you're storming out or making a scene
it's you're obviously not wanted here so
okay I'm gonna leave Netflix
obviously doesn't want our business so
all right they have every right to put
that garbage on their platform if they
want to they don't but it's clear that
that it's it's it's
put there simply to kick us in the shins
basically as Christian so alright
message received
now I also want to echo the point that
many have made already and it's a good
point so I think it should be repeated
because I know people some people will
try to defend Netflix and this
quote-unquote comedy troupe by saying
well there's value in taking down sacred
cows in in insulting the things that
people hold dear just for the sake of it
just because as an expression of
creative freedom and blah blah blah now
I don't buy that argument I don't think
there is value and tearing something
down simply for the sake of it I think
there's value in tearing something down
if it's if it's if it deserves to be
torn down if it needs to be torn down
then yeah it's tear down and if it's if
it needs to be torn down and it's
something that people cherish then so
what they shouldn't cherish it okay but
tearing something down for the sake of
it I don't think there's any value in
that but at any rate that's not even
what these cowards are doing because
notice they do this to Christians they
do this with Jesus they would never do
this with other groups like for instance
Muslims okay so you're not gonna see a
hilarious comedy sketch where Mohammed
is a gay man that where the where the
whole punchline is Mohammed is gay
you're not going to see that you're only
going to see that with Christians so
that
refuge of claiming this is about freedom
of expressions about free speech this is
about being bold and brave
it's that brave look to insult
Christians that what's brave about that
everybody does that everybody in
Hollywood does it the media so you
insult Christians then you know you're
putting yourself on the same side as all
of the most powerful institutions in the
West and especially if you're a
filmmaker or comedy troupe Hollywood's
gonna love it they do it all the time
nothing brave about that and your own
physical safety will not be threatened
because Christians don't respond to
these kinds of provocations by with
suicide bombs that that's just not how
Christians respond to this stuff
so nothing brave nothing courageous now
to do that with Muslims with Mohammed
now you're putting something on the line
now you're risking something socially
because that's not going to be accepted
in Hollywood and you're also probably
risking your physical safety so you're
not gonna do that because it's not about
that this is about this is about a just
scoring a cheap point and as I said fine
Netflix doesn't want our business that's
all they don't want why would you why
would anyone continue to give their
business to someone who doesn't want it
if you walked in to the local grocery
store and the owner came out and said
you're a piece of garbage I hate you I
don't want you in here your money is no
good here screw you you turn around and
leave right how emasculated and
henpecked would you have to be to say
okay but I'm still gonna give you my mom
will you please take my money though
will you please still take it I know you
hate me but will you take it no we're
not gonna do that we shouldn't do that
before you before we move on here let's
let's check in with our friends from
honey honey is a free browser extension
that automatically finds the best promo
codes whenever you shop online this is
something you really want to pay
attention to as we get into into the
holidays as we get into Christmas this
means you always get the best deals
without even trying on over 20,000 sites
such as Amazon Target Best Buy and more
honey has found it's over 10 million
members over a billion dollars in
savings I feel like I have to emphasize
that 10 million members over a billion
dollars in savings that these members
have gotten through honey supports over
20,000 stores online like I said and if
you you know if you don't if you don't
you don't want to believe me then go and
check out the over 100,000 plus
five-star reviews on the group the
google chrome store I can tell you I've
been using this thing for my holiday
shopping which has just made it a lot
easier and I would save a ton of money
as well there's there's there's no
reason to not get this if you're buying
gifts this holiday season then you need
honey and if you're not buying gift and
you probably know someone is so let them
know about it honey can help you make
sure that you getting the best price for
whatever you're buying it's free to use
it installs in just two clicks get honey
for free yet join honey dot-com slash
walls that's join honey dot-com slash
Walsh well you know Barack Obama a man
who's single-handedly prevented a woman
from becoming president 2008 he recently
said maybe you heard about this he was
given a speech and he said that it is
that that women are indisputably better
leaders than men indisputably he
constructed this utopian vision of an
estrogen-filled future and said these
quote absolutely confident there would
be significant improvement in all
aspects of life if every nation on earth
was run by a woman for even just two
years so two years of women running
everything and and the whole world would
be improved drastically now he did allow
in the speech that women are quote not
perfect so he did say that but he said
that they're better than us meaning men
and despite having chosen himself an old
man
and not a woman an old man as his
running mate for both of his
presidential campaigns he also laid the
blame for the state of the world on at
the feet of old men who refused to get
out of the way so this is the rhetoric
that he's going with I think maybe all
you need to say in response to this
simpering ridiculous nonsense is just
speak for yourself
Obama if you feel like you were an
inadequate leader then I'm inclined to
agree and if you feel like pretty much
any woman would have been better than
you sure I'm with you on that but I
don't think your problem was an excess
of testosterone I don't think that was
the issue now
as to this idea that women are better
leaders than men and Obama is not the
only person that you hear this from you
hear from feminists too it's a common
common talking point on the left
especially well there's no evidence
whatsoever that women are inherently
better leaders than men women have led
many countries throughout history there
are several countries today that are run
by women so you can go and look and you
know if female leadership spawned
drastic improvements across the board we
should have quantifiable evidence of
that by now you should be able to look
and see well when women take over look
at all these things everything gets
better well that's not actually what you
see it kind of depends on the woman just
like it depends on the man as far as
leadership goes besides I think personal
experience would maybe call into
question Obama's claim that exclusive
female leadership would bring peace and
harmony throughout the globe because
because and I'll try to say this
delicately but women are good at many
things certainly but peaceful and
drama-free cooperation with each other
doesn't quite make the top ten of that
list so when you hear this stuff but if
a women ran everything there'd be no
more Wars are you sure I think that
would at least be the same number of
wars maybe even more actually because
that's not you know that's it's a
stereotype that women often struggle to
get along with each other
it's a stereotype but it's a stereotype
for a reason
this is definitely a lot of truth to it
but the larger point putting that aside
because as I said when it comes to
leadership really it just it depends on
the person there are some women who
would make great leaders there some I'm
going to be terrible leaders just like
with men but the larger point is this
and I always go back to this I feel like
I have to go back to it because I just I
think we need to demand consistency from
people and the problem for Democrats is
that they can't engage in this kind of
you go girl stuff anymore
it's like they somehow keep forgetting
all the things they've been saying about
gender for the last ten or fifteen years
they can't talk about the gifts and
abilities of women nor can they contrast
women with men in order to highlight the
the advantages of female leadership and
so on it's not just that they come off
like pathetic suck-ups when they do that
but it's that their own ideology
precludes this form of sucking up you
you can't do it anymore
because these are the very same people
who tell us that women are equal to men
in every respect and there is no such
thing as a unique female personality
trait or unique female characteristics
and by the way if there was if you could
say now Obama wants to say that women
are he wants to ascribe certain positive
personality traits to women and if
you're gonna go down that road then you
also have to allow that there are
negative personality traits that are
unique or specially manifested in women
you can't just say that it's positive
that's not how people work nobody has
only positive traits but regardless you
this is a road you can't explore it all
if you're on the left because Democrats
would actually reject the idea if you
ask them that
there are any personality traits
exclusive to women good or bad actually
and in fact they won't even admit that
female reproductive organs are exclusive
to women they won't even stay won't even
admit that a woman's body is exclusive
to a woman by their version of reality
there is no objective difference between
men and women and as I've discussed
plenty of times in the past they aren't
they aren't willing or even able to
offer so much as a definition for woman
so when Obama says women this women that
women we've got if you were to raise
your hand in the audience and say you
keep talking about women what what is
that what do you mean by that he
wouldn't be able to answer the question
he could not answer it
when I say could not for someone like
Obama it's not that he doesn't know the
answer but he his ideology prevents him
from saying it he knows the answer he
knows what a woman is most of these
people on the Left do especially the
older people on the Left who lived say
40 or 50 years of their lives never once
entertaining or mentioning this idea
that men can get pregnant and all this
kind of stuff and then it lasts 5 or 10
years they switch courses and abandoned
the the scientific reality that they had
known for for all that time so Obama
knows the truth but he can't say he
won't say it if you ask him and so
that's it according to them anyone with
anybody and any brain and any character
trait can be a woman also any person
with the body and brain of a woman can
be a man or something else entirely and
this state of affairs makes nonsense of
all feminist rhetoric it all goes out
the window a statement like women are
better at such and such requires that
women are a discernible group with
identifying features in common when you
say women you have to be referring to
something if they aren't then nothing
can be said about them
or bad women are everything at once and
nothing in particular in effect they
don't exist there is no such thing as
women anymore there are no women there
are no men we are all part of some
ambiguous mass of indistinguishable
humanity that's that's all there is
anymore and that's supposed to be
Obama's message doesn't make for a very
inspiring speech but that's supposed to
be his message and I think we have to
hold him to it that's what I say to
conservatives even if you sound like a
broken record which I do sometimes or
often we got to hold them to this that's
their claim that they have their gender
ideology we have to hold them to it all
the time so anytime they start talking
about women they start they start acting
like the word woman means something to
them we have to see we have to step in
and remind them oh to know that you
can't use that word anymore that doesn't
mean anything to you
and if they protest that it does then
just ask them okay what does it mean
they can't answer it I really I mean I
think that we should just never move on
from this fact we should never move on
and talk about anything else because the
fact is you've got one half of the
political divide that these days cannot
define the word woman and we should
never move up we should force them like
how can we move on and talk about
anything else when you don't even know
what this word means this is basic words
and you don't even know what they mean
anymore you need to figure out what
these words mean or weak we really can't
talk about anything it's amazing to me
that conservatives let liberals get away
with this political debates cable cable
news debates conservatives will sit
there and let liberals use a word like
women and they never stop and say what
does that mean to you I've never seen
anyone do it how have I never seen
anyone do that how is no one no one ever
done this I want to see a a left
put on the spot on TV with this question
that's what I want to say so if you're a
conservative watching this and you're
gonna do a cable news head if you're in
the media or you're a politician you're
gonna be doing a debate some time I want
put them on this but the first time they
say the word woman stop them and say
what does that mean give me a definition
it's like we're letting them get away
with it
we're letting them get away with holding
this this their gender ideology its
total nonsense it's completely insane
it has erased everything they've said
about gender for the last 50 years and
we're letting them get away with it like
we report where we're helping them by
pretending we don't notice how insane it
is I mean imagine imagine if there was a
politician who either party who was a
flat earther who believed the earth was
flat and unfortunately there are more
people than you would like to believe
these days who do believe the earth is
flat but what if a politician what have
a senator or someone came out and said
the earth is flat would you ever be able
to take anything they say seriously
again would you ever if you were ever if
you were a candidate opposing them in an
election would you allow there to be an
ever any debate that doesn't come back
to that point like would you allow them
to ever move on would you allow them to
say oh yeah I think the earth is flat
anyway let's talk about this over here
know every chance you got you would say
no no no no no no no no stop wait a
second let's go back to the earth being
flat thing we're not going to skip over
that way we need to explore that yet we
let the left do this we let Democrat
politicians do this they have all made a
claim about science that is as insane in
fact I would say more insane than the
claim that the earth is flat their claim
that a biological male with male
reproductive organs can be a woman their
claim that men can give birth every
Democrat on the national stage every
single one of them would claim or has
claimed that men can give birth they all
believe that or at least they will
pretend to believe it that is again as
crazy in fact no more crazy much crazier
than saying the earth is flat and yet we
let these people move on and talk about
other things without demanding that they
justify that claim every time they say
anything we should stop them and say
yeah but you think men can give birth so
you're crazy you're just insane I'm not
I mean until you until you drop that I
why should I listen to anything you say
about any topic all right you know this
holiday season do your friends and
family do your friends and family a
solid by getting them a daily wired gift
membership and the good news for you
from now until January 1st and so this
doesn't just end at Christmas goes all
the way January 1st all insider plus
gift memberships will be 25% off that
means your loved ones will get all the
fantastic perks plus the majestic
glorious beautiful leftist tears tumblr
and you'll get the savings so they get
to they get the perk you get the savings
that's 25% off all insider plus gift
memberships this holiday season go to
daily wired.com slash gift to get your
twenty five percent off again that's
daily wire.com slash gift to get your
twenty five percent off give them a gift
they'll thank you for all year long all
right speaking of crazy that could be my
transition for every topic I do on the
show reading ow again from The Daily
wire on Monday video emerged of the
performance of transgender stripper
Beyonce black st. James I think that's
the whole name Beyonce black st. James
I'm thinking probably not the Christian
name at the annual conference of
adilyn King County officials on solving
homelessness on December 9th
Christopher Ruffo a contributing editor
for the city journal posted the video on
Twitter commenting here's how they're
using taxpayer money the incident in
question prompted the King County
Department of Community and Health and
Human Services to place Kiera
Zylstra organizer of the conference at
South Seattle College on leave last
Thursday journalist Erica C Barnett
reported Denise Roth leutner deputy
director of King County's Department of
Community Human Services said in an
email the department is aware of an
event that occurred during the all home
annual conference on December 9 2019 we
have placed a director of all home on
administrative leave pending the results
of an investigation into the event and
and the leadership of all home the
Seattle Times reported that Zylstra was
paid roughly 123 thousand dollars
annually according to a County
spokesperson The Times added that the
only note on the agenda for the annual
conference was lunch with cultural
presentation without a warning or
announcement about the performance
itself now there is a video of this
performance of the transgender stripper
I will not play it especially after
everything I said last week about
pornography but it is out there cultural
presentation have you ever heard of
better euphemism for a for something
that's the euphemism they're using for a
transgender striptease a cultural
presentation can you imagine going
that's all they put on the agenda
apparently you would have no idea they
said come down for lunch we're gonna do
a cultural presentation and then next
thing you know you see a man with fake
breasts taking us clothes off on the
stage what where is the culture in that
what is what's cultural about that where
is the culture in a male with fake
breasts taking his clothes off but see I
think this this story is important to
take note of one because it once again
highlights the complete descent into
insanity that's happening on the left
but also because Democrats say oh you
got to give us more money we need more
money more money more tax money and if
you give us more money we're gonna do
things like solve homelessness Bernie
Sanders makes this claim all the time
give him more money more money more
money and we'll solve homeless Lee
you'll have will have a utopia no
homelessness no drug addiction no
starving people everyone's got
everything you know no more student debt
well the Democrats in Seattle they got
tax money to solve homelessness and this
is what they this is what they meant by
we're gonna solve homelessness what they
meant is transgender stripper so keep
that in mind let's go to emails Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Chris says Matt
your disastrous and frankly dangerously
heretical guidance on cooking the sweet
ambrosia that is salty delicious pork
belly simply called bacon by the
untutored is nothing short of inciting
vandalism you might as well champion
drawing crayon mustaches on the Mona
Lisa every man with an orderly mind and
properly educated in the preparation of
the gift God literally blessed mankind
with on a table cloth from the heavens
knows it must be grilled only a searing
well seasoned grill provides the proper
balance of heat and carbon required to
allow the internal fat to reach just
that crispy and tender homeostasis which
yields a perfect sweetness that can set
off any dish from omelet stoy stirs to
only bacon indeed the only acceptable
justification for cooking bacon in a
skillet is a need to save and use the
drippings to later infuse into a bottle
of Kentucky Bourbon your distorted views
on this topic make me question your
suitability for any future tyrannical
aspirations well Chris I spent 10
minutes on my show talking about bacon
while other shows are talking about
breaking news important news like
impeachment I'm sitting here talking
about bacon okay that's the kind of
commitment you get from me
when it comes to this topic is there any
other show host anyone else in
conservative media anywhere who's gonna
spend ten minutes of a show talking
about how to cook bacon maybe there's a
reason for that possible
but that's what I did and and your
response is to criticize me your
response rather than writing me an email
saying thank you so much Matt for that
beautiful presentation thank you for
calling calling attention to this thank
you for raising awareness about the
proper way to cook bacon thank you for
that you are a hero you deserve the
Nobel Prize you are a genius now instead
of that which is what I expect I get
criticism unbelievable and you expect me
to believe that you know how to cook
bacon because you know cooking bacon
comes down to character it comes down to
what kind of a person are you
and I firmly believe if you if you
cannot probably cook bacon that's a
reflection of your character it's
obviously it you have character flaws
one of them in gratitude so no I don't
want your ungrateful bacon you don't
need I showed you the the the
photographic evidence you saw it for
yourself
so maybe need to expand your mind a
little I don't need a fancy grill I'll
put it on a skillet I could cook the
bacon on a hot furnace okay I could cook
it I could cook it on the street on a 90
degree day and it's gonna look that good
it's not about the tools you use Chris
it's about the it's about the the spirit
the love that you put into it that's
what I believe I'm Dario from Jeff
greetings Matt I really appreciate your
show and all you do I agree with your
race recent stances on pornography
Christmas decorations and bacon but I
can't let your those are the things I've
been talking about it's true but I can't
let your error regarding the worst
Christmas song ever go unchecked the
worst Christmas song ever is by the
other solo Beatle artist John Lennon
happy xmas war is over the song is so
bad I can only attribute your error so
your subconscious mind forgetting that
it does in fact exist I've attached a
link to this putrid garbage and I
apologize in advance if you click on it
yeah well it is a terrible song
obviously Jeff from John Lennon he had a
few terrible songs that being one of
them but everyone knows it's a terrible
song so this is like Christmas shoes or
that benefit song from the 80s or was it
called do they know it's Christmas
everybody knows those are terrible songs
and you don't really hear them that much
anyway the fact that wonderful Christmas
time has played so much and it's
embraced by so many people is what puts
it over the top is the worst Christmas
song of all time in my view it's like if
we were talking about the worst movie of
all time you could go the easy route and
say Battlefield Earth or what was that
Ben Affleck JLo movie from the early
2000s jiggly or Julie or whatever was
called you could say well those are the
yeah I mean obviously those are in the
running for the worst movies of all time
but everyone knows they're terrible
nobody likes them so that's why I would
say the worst movie of all time my
opinion the worst movie of all time is
avatar because it was really really
really really really bad and boring and
derivative bordering on plagiarizing but
also it made a billion dollars which
accentuates the badness and makes it all
the more important that we denounce it
and so that's what I would say about
wonderful christmastime
clearly there are other songs that are
just as bad objectively speaking but
it's the fact that this song is played
incessantly and I really don't know why
because I haven't met one person in my
life ever who likes this song and I've
asked all of them every person I mean I
asked them this question it's kind of
weird it's an obsession of mine if you
couldn't tell cuz I spent 15 minutes on
that
spend 15 minutes on wonderful
christmastime dissecting it line by line
the next show I spend 10 minutes on
begging anyway this is from Sara says hi
Matt you gave us your thoughts on the
worst Christmas song ever but what is
the worst version of a classmate
Christmas song classic of a classic
Christmas song ever I'm going with the
Johnny Cash hark the herald abomination
now I had no idea that Johnny Cash did a
hark the herald rendition but he did
apparently so let's let's take a quick
listen to that
[Music]
I think that wasn't so bad I mean I love
Johnny Cash lung bias it's it's not
great it's a little weird
not really Johnny Cash's style not the
version of hark the herald that I would
listen to but it's not even close to the
worst no the worst rendition rendition
of a classic Christmas song I think this
is easy this is Christina Aguilera did
an oh holy night friend ition and the
fact that she butchers such a beautiful
song is what makes it all the worse but
let's listen to part of that
Oh Holy Night the stars are brightly
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
today the world hints it I never
[Music]
and the song
yeah okay just sing the song Christina
sing the damn song Christmas hymns are
not a time for showing off your vocal
range the Christmas songs and this is
what I call hymns any song that's sang
in a church or that could that is a song
that would be appropriate to sing in a
church any of these songs hymns gospel
songs any of it it's not about you
this singer you sing a song you sing it
traditionally I don't I don't want to
hear it you you mixing it up a little
bit and trying to do your own cute thing
with it just sing the song all right
this is from Nathan says Matt I've heard
your opinion about the worst Christmas
song but what about the best enough with
the negativity I don't know why you
accuse me of negativity I'm nothing but
a ray of sunshine all I ever do is look
on the bright side I'm honestly shocked
that you would say that about me this
show could be titled the bright side
with Matt Walsh maybe that should be the
title actually because that's all I do
as I say listen let's not focus on the
bad things in life let's all just be
happy that isn't that my message anyway
best Christmas song well there are two
categories here there's the secular
commercial Christmas song the
traditional hymn obviously the hymns are
better but I'll give you the best of
both categories so for commercial songs
the best is obviously white Christmas
specifically the Bing Crosby version
really every Bing Crosby Christmas song
it's beginning to look a lot like
Christmas that's a another great one as
for hymns I'm partial to Oh come o come
Emmanuel which is every time I say this
this is why any time I say this every
Catholic jumps in is a that's not a
Christmas song it's an Advent song
that's Advocaat Christmas I know it's an
Advent song I'm aware of that but it's
still my I considered a Christmas song
also because I really like it's my
favorite also though I would say o come
all ye faithful beautiful song joy to
the world is also a great hark the
herald holy night the First Noel I mean
they're all superb when it comes to
traditional Christmas hymns there is
there isn't a bad one they're all good
but uh probably if oh come okay if I
can't count oh come o come Emmanuel then
I would probably say o come all ye
faithful now this is from will do one
more system well there's no name given
says hey Matt my husband and I are new
listeners to your show we really
appreciate your humor and the topics
that you cover my husband and I recently
had a son and on our journey to becoming
parents we went through fertility
treatment thank God that we didn't need
to do IVF as IVF would not have been an
option for us as pro-lifers IVF as you
probably know harvests it fertilizes a
dozen eggs at once but the woman is only
given two of those eggs during
implantation the woman is then given the
option for the renaming or for the
remaining should say now embryos to
either be donated to science thrown away
or adopted out the it or frozen right
indefinitely I think isn't also an
option the adopted out part caught my
interest embryo adoption is definitely a
thing it also apparently is way cheaper
than IVF I think five hundred dollars
instead of ten thousand per cycle as
averages average prices this seems like
a great alternative to IVF instead of
just adding to the number of frozen or
discarded babies they even allow for a
fee of course to know the gender and
test for abnormalities or diseases prior
to adoption what are your thoughts on
adopting an embryo and do you think that
it's strange that more people haven't
heard of this as an option maybe because
it lends itself to the argument that
life starts at conception I mean if you
can tell the baby's gender or genetic
makeup before they start growing into
the in the womb how can they still
debate that it's human life and how do
you adapt someone if it's not human life
thanks for your time look forward to
hearing your thoughts so this is a
fascinating topic and as you correctly
point out this is the problem one of the
problems with IVF you end up with these
extra fertilized eggs which are then
frozen indefinitely discarded hand it
over to a science lab as you mentioned
or adopted but this is the most blatant
example of the commodification of human
life that I can think of where you have
surplus embryos that you now treat like
packages of ground beef that you store
in the freezer throw them out when
they've been there too long yet the fact
remains that people do this and so the
embryos are there
and now I think there's something like a
million frozen embryos in the country
right now as we speak
and so something has to be done with
them and it would seem to me that
adopting them would be a very valid and
moral path to explore the other options
are some form of destruction so seems
obvious to me that adopting them and
letting them develop and grow and have a
life is the best option I don't see how
someone could argue that destroying them
is better than that now so that's what I
would say about embryo adoption I think
it's considering you you you could argue
that well the this commodification of
human life that's happening is a bad
thing
a moral atrocity and so even by adopting
the embryos are you somehow
participating in that process helping to
perpetuate it I guess you could make
that argument I wouldn't find that
argument convincing because I don't
think you are participating in it I
think they're coming in to rescue these
human life from the clutches of
destruction I do think there's another
aspect to this question though it seems
clear to me that the mote that the just
thing to do - or rather for an embryo is
to adopt it but we also have to ask ask
the question what about the born
children the many born children who are
in the adoption system waiting for homes
if you're a couple looking to adopt if
that's an option for you you have the
the wherewithal the will the the money
and the resources everything and you
want to adopt Koons an argument be made
that you should perhaps focus on the
born children who need to be adopted
over the embryos now I'm obviously not
pulling the old pro-lifers only care
about born children or don't care about
born children I'm obviously not pulling
that card but I think that it's clear
that born children have a capacity for
suffering for longing for desiring a
bond
family that frozen embryos do not this
doesn't mean that the frozen embryos are
unhuman that's not the argument I'm
making don't get me wrong but does this
factor mean that when deciding which to
adopt our focus ought to be on the child
who is actively waiting for a family and
who is really suffering from the want of
one I think a good argument can be made
in that direction now there's there's a
lot we don't know about embryos human
embryos there's a lot that still remains
mysterious but I think we can say with a
fair amount of certainty that they don't
have the conscious experience that say a
two-year-old child or three-year-old
child or child of any age has in the
adoption system and so when you think
about it that way I think there's that
adds an extra element there but that
isn't to say that couples who adopt
embryos are doing something wrong or
they've committed a moral crime against
children who are in the adoption system
I don't think that at all at the end of
the day you got to do what's right for
your family I just think that's another
factor to weigh and for me I know that
that is what would stop me from adopting
an embryo because if I was exploring
adoption I probably would be focused on
the children who are waiting in the
system really suffering and wanting and
waiting for a family all right but
really interesting topic and I
appreciate the email I guess we'll leave
it there thanks everybody for watching
and listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there